[Musique]
de la vie si tous kankan est astucieux
bell bell
adoli c'est le plus sérieux à jouer il
suffit de vouloir revenir à un ami
à tous encore aujourd hui contente de
loire bonjour fabrice grange en tout cas
encore bonjour à tous et à toutes
salut nos petits amis silverlight j'ai
commencé par jour puis conduit bonjour
bonjour voila voila c'est fait oui tu
passé rempli comboul reste que le
vatican boucheron c'est le petit jeu de
la géographie ou la géographie d'accord
alors j'en rappelle brièvement comment
les choses se passent
vous allez regarder une carte de
géographie sur la carte mu est
d'ailleurs guy muette comme une carpe un
oui c'est ça bravo au tuc encore ça
commence bien
alors vous regardez une carte de
géographie vous essayez de deviner quel
est le nom du pays en question
bon c'est tout con qui a préparé cela
mais pour vous aider vous aurez
également le drapeau du pays et la façon
de dire bonjour dans la langue du pays
ce qui n'est pas toujours facile info
2010 s'est pas fait s'il s'est pas c'est
pas tout ça c'est pas fait pour être
intéressant parfaite as tu un tu
déconnes cette belle fleur derrière toi
regardez tous attentivement
voici la carte géographique de ce pays
vous voyez ici la capitale c'est un
petit point noir la mer mais le pays bon
moi je commence à avoir une petite idée
tout de même pas le drapeau elle le
drapeau le drapeau du pays c'est
important je précise que les couleurs
sont les suivantes
ici vous avez le bleu ici c'est du jaune
avec un motif au milieu et enfin à
droite à droite c'est rouge
bon ça devrait mettre sur la voie donc
bah il me semble que ça devrait aller à
peu près ça effectivement on peut aller
plus loin on peut aller plus loin on
peut dire bonjour dans la langue du pays
est capable toit de prononcer sa ben je
ne suis pas certain de la prononciation
hélas je dirais bout nazi n'a pas boudé
nazis la boule asie où la ville sénat
tout le monde peut-être ou lèvres ou
l'azinat tout le monde
vous avez une idée de du pays en
question vous voyez n'ont pas encore
tout à fait bien regardez bien j'ai
l'impression très nette mon cher toucan
qu'il s'agit de la roumanie et bain avec
ici la capitale qui est bucarest la mer
noire
ici le drapeau et bouna zina en roumain
qui est une langue latine comme la nôtre
comme le français là bonjour ses
bouddhas zina bah écoutes je m'en suis
pas trop mal sorti tout de même c'est
très bien c'est très beau tu vas aller
dans le jardin oui je prends piquant
bull avec moi un pub est un genre de
relire avaler à tout à l'heure
didon j'ai des grenouilles qui sont
dehors fait attention mais attention les
piétine pas bon alors vous êtes prévenus
vous entendez en étalant des psys le jeu
et du poids comme le bleu comme celui
mais bien sûr mais charles votre rôle
oui vous le relations dans ces pays
fabrice oui mais voilà voilà voilà
j'arrive fait pas trop difficile parce
que attention hein
il est trop tôt pour voir
oui raconte ou apple points communs ah
bah je vous réexpliquer le point commun
alors je rappelle josé voilà vous allez
entendre tout cancan belles belles et
pousse moussu non ils vont chacun
représenté quelque chose ou une personne
enfin ils ont un rôle à jouer et vous
vous devez savoir très exactement ce qui
les réunit quel est le point commun
qu'ils ont entre eux je pense que c'est
à peu près ça et je pense que vous êtes
tous prêts à mourir est belle tout en
restituant bulls 1 2 milliard à spa
tétouan des buts on regarde ta tirelire
et sur le sur la balustrade a alors
alors moi voilà je suis extrêmement
utile oui tu as besoin de communiquer
avec des amis lointains battu remarque
dans ce cas l'on peut enfin une lettre
mais quand on veut que ça aille vite
1 et qu'est ce qu'on fait on prend son
téléphone ou bien on envoie un
télégramme
et puis en quelques secondes on a la
réponse c'est formidable ça alors on
prévient ses amis qu'on arrive
allez hop on se sert de moi et c'est
fait et c'est pour ça qu'on me trouve
d'ailleurs le long des routes
tu les as vu tu sais ces poteaux en
ciment bois et céline qui font comme
nous portée musicale
d'ailleurs les les petites hirondelles
de notre ami pouces moussu aime bien se
poser deux si oui car elle avait alors
si ça c'est toi
ah bon moi je pense que je ne vous
apprendrai rien en vous disant que je
suis une vraie petite fée du logis fait
d'accord avec vous et bien sûr une
tension et je te dis fonderie maintenant
je sais que je fais moi même mes robes
et mais chapeau
évidemment pour cela j'ai besoin de pas
mal de choses tu sais que la maison j'ai
une très belle machine à coudre et en
voyage j'ai toujours une petite trousse
qui contiennent tout ce qu'il faut pour
recoudre un bouton ou réparer un accroc
qui s'y ajouter un trou est ton pantalon
tu peux venir me le demande et si oui et
il sait ce que je représente aujourd'hui
bien cela fait partie de mon petit
matériel
si tu as besoin de mes services je te le
redis ne te gêne pas je serais ravi de
te prouver mes talents à la fin oui j'ai
une petite idée mais je voudrais quand
même je pense que tout le monde sera
d'accord avec moi fois écouter la
version 2 pouces moussu parce que tout à
fait sûr en bas âge et tu sais moi moi
ce que je suis aujourd'hui je ne sais
pas pourquoi mais on me dit souvent que
je n'ai pas inventé ça doit être vrai je
sais pas du tout qui l'a inventé
d'ailleurs je suis très fin très mince
très souple très léger et est très
résistant je dois reconnaître que je
suis pas très très à la mode maintenant
non mon emploi de moins en moins pas
forcément forcément chez les camions
on vend le beurre maintenant tout
empaqueté toutou pesé alors moi bah je
me rouille et puis je m'ennuie dans mon
coin
enfin si tu trouves tu ne le dira pas ce
que ça tu me diras qui m'a inventé ça ça
me ferait bien plaisir
tu vois ce que je veux dire mais je ne
sais pas qui tu as inventé mais je crois
maintenant savoir peut pas de quoi il
s'agit
toukan qu'on ne saurait du point un
filtre graphique et belles belles pas du
fils du fil à coudre zalla et enfin
pouces moussu c'est le fameux fil à
couper le beurre
voilà que l'on trouve plus tellement
effectivement aujourd'hui on a encore
été bête a pas dit dans mes enfants
aient des six que je suis là pour me
défendre et pour me battre et j'ai
trouvé ma vie je vais voir si dans le
prochain jeu musical que je vais te
préparer tu veux savoir aussi bien t'es
débrouillé
la suite c'est à toi c moi ce que tu
aimes lalonde hui aux teintes à des
verts qui te monte à près de man est
annoncée alors que jamais besoin de
regarder il peut regarder non mais oui
oui malheur tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure tous nos sujets sont à toi et
c'est à nous maintenant affamé on y va
tu es prêt oui je suis pareil alors vas
au tabac langue dans l'agglo j'espère
que tu n'as pas oublié ton petit crayon
regarde ton marqueur haut rhinois bravo
train c'est formidable et ça grâce à
cuba alors aujourd'hui je vais te
proposer un mot en neuf lettres à une
annonce
oui oui 9 face à celle où on à paris
alors quoi la première c1 et iri
j'espère que tu as fait des progrès leur
taux grimper au delà j'ai travaillé j'ai
travaillé un i alors il a pris la dérive
et un 4/5 ses 7,7 petit trailer bien et
tu me dis après eux et à eux faire ça
moi voilà voilà
bon c'est bien on y va on y va j'étais
courir alors c'est à sète c'est une
fleur à nos goûts nos os est pas une
plante non seynois une plante
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être un
animal un animal assez bien un gros
anneaux à petit après un petit animal
qui rend non non tu es par un insecte
non conscient rana sec non un animal qui
volent wii qui votent à l'affût brûle
latine là c'est un oiseau danoise du
film tu sais tu que je t'aide je vais te
donner la deuxième lettre
oui je veux bien aller dans la deuxième
demie les 1ers à air chaud oui au 1er et
un noise aux oiseaux va vraiment
c'est-à-dire un oiseau qui commence
partir alors là vraiment je t ai d1 avec
un il est cependant possible comme c'est
pas possible tu veux pas en parler d'une
hirondelle unis rodelle un pauvre pouces
mousson mais c'est vraiment c'est la
déchéance
lorsque hirondelles avec un oui comment
ça s'écrit tout guingamp hirondelles
ses cris j'ai écrit i mondial-2011 mail
pauvre pouces moussu h d'abord pour
commencer il ya un attachement fin aux
lâches et mondial-2010 écrit
l'hirondelle malheureux pouces mousmari
la ville c'est vraiment catastrophe
modèle c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
je n'y comprends plus rien mais enfin tu
dois avoir raison mais tu sais que les
hirondelles
non elles s'en vont à la fin de l'été
pour retrouver des climats plus chauds
bah elles font un grand voyage et elles
connaissent très bien la météo
elle ne parle jamais s'il ya une tempête
qui s'annonce sur leur route
ah ah et si les hommes étaient aussi
forts et bien ce serait bien agréable à
voir
oui c'est vrai tu n'est peut-être pas
très fort en orthographe mais des
connaissances de la nature nous sont
précieuses tout de même poursuivi ses
contacts à l'abri une hirondelle ne fait
pas le printemps
c'est pas c'est un dicton tu as raison
tout commence à 10 $ trouver belle bella
ben oui on y va
[Musique]
rituel belle mais ça va est-ce que tu
m'aimes toujours je t'adore tu le sais
bien
tidjane thiam avec moi oui au petit jeu
musical jeu musical je rappelle comment
les choses fonctionnent cities bon alors
pour ce jeu musical
vous avez devant vous une portée
musicale avec une clé de sol
j'ai des notes dans les mains que je
vais placer au fur et à mesure que bell
bell va me raconter une histoire
et lorsqu'elle ne terminera pas un mot
lorsqu'elle frappe
oui ou bien tout bien combien voit pas
mais qu'elle ferait un bruit bizarre
il faudra que je remplace la syllabe qui
manque par le nom d'une note cite le
mieux c'est de le faire toutes les
courses et il fallait je vais te
raconter une petite histoire
ou enfin si tu préfères un petit ah oui
un petit rets si belle voix la halle à
cette fois il faut qu'il fasse très
attention les gars qu'on ne se rasent
arrive à la fin de mon histoire t aura
une surprise oui
alors aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire d'un
homme important un grand seigneur il
habite une très belle demeure en château
du c'est avec une tour un pont levis et
il se marie avec une très jolie femme
ravissante seulement ce grand seigneur
s'ennuie comme une vieille croûte de
parra pardon racines à six wi fi
eh bien non seulement ce grand seigneur
ne supporte pas de rester toute la
journée à khroub dans sa chambre à
assise en vidéo laisse le jouer s'il te
plaît crois que je suis ami qui peut
alors retard oui oui elle passe ses
papilles 2 puisque nous sommes en train
de jouer puis je mettre seul avec
fabrice alors yuko tig
figure toi que ce grand seigneur apprend
que ça va mal dans la région alors il
décide d'aller lutter contre
l'envahisseur oui il met sa plus belle
armure
il fait
les adieux à sa femme dit un jour je vis
en plus il passé simple maintenant parce
que le présent ça va pas alors il fit
ses adieux à sa femme et un jour il en a
il s'en alla vers la chambre la tiens je
n'ai encore fait une note là et voilà il
espérait revenir vite tu sais ce grand
seigneur à pâques ou à la trinité
ça te dit quelque chose hélas à la
guerre ou ne se fait pas de cap ou de
quoi quoi comme à noël tu sèmes se fait
pas de cadeaux voilà et je signe ce
senior très courageuse m n'a pas du tout
réussi où mme ruby oui harb a réussi et
voilà la surprise que j'étais préparé
relie les notes que tu a placé alors
nous avons ré si si si la docile et si
tu les chiens que ses notes à bala
attends je vais jouer un petit peu de ça
sans connaître une charge à longwy
chanson tous les enfants connaissent a
alors je joue mal et c'est la gauche
malroux s'en va-t-en guerre du congo
fini de jouer je ne trouve pas ça être
là ça fait très très ccc la gauche
s'allie 12 il est là le soleil
mais ce pas jouer puis croulant phare de
l'embarras de tranquille à fabrice jard
et vient côté du noir assez d'accord et
chanter à 100 tu te rappelles notre chat
sont bien sûr les quatre déjà papa d'amy
est à peu près que la vie s'est désisté
léger choc se déchausse les comme juni
pas de baignoire negro a fait attention
les quatre amis sont descendus ti les
yaks ça me sont heureux car ils aiment à
mai
oui
d
il n'avait pas joué aujourd'hui et
[Musique]
vouloir devenir amis
voilà je te fais des bisous
[Musique]